if there's a fish in my movie they
better [ __ ]
um there's our there's our animated line
there's our made live that's great by
the way um so i actually
did do another one last week that i went
through and animated it was something
that austin said
no no it was it was you troy you said to
austin did you get a new camera
and i i did go through and animate it
but i ended up cutting the start of the
show because we didn't have mike's audio
yet and i couldn't get i couldn't get it
to balance without sounding terrible
so i had to cut the the time i do i'm
sorry well troy gave you another chance
because it was literally the first thing
he said again this time that's true i
wasn't recording
it's called the safety take i if for
some reason
aliens ever need to know or like a
future civilization
or if we need to like do ai and like go
what is a human
face i think it should be elana pierces
because in the same behalf of all of us
yeah she's like the ambassador the space
probe voyager
has like bits of humanity on it
so does alana's face it's especially
especially this particular expression
the smirking
yeah skepticism she was making a face
when she first was
hearing him just like this yeah my face
that's the face she always makes when
she sees us
so that's the standard reaction what is
that how do you do that well i'm very
expressive and i've been told that i'm
overly expressive to mask the fact that
i'm not very emotional
so i go wow yeah so apparently i'm
overly expressive
at that point that's ridiculous to a
therapist
uh that yeah really wow okay
well what do they know because they
don't have a dramatic emotions
apparently i faked them to seem more
human so the ploy worked and i should be
the alien representative of human what
your counselor were you going to that
was like you're not really
my audio was too loud at the start so
apologies for that editing challenge
when you get to it
you're you're one week off of being
[ __ ] all over the place
yeah really standards of standards have
slipped i apologize
that uh they were never that high in the
first place that overly
expressive thing i picture you at
starbucks
or like a you know take out counter
where they're like uh
we got a latte for alana it just cuts to
you like
oh my god yeah fake tears on demand
yeah the quivering lip of of yeah
exactly like ma'am it's just a coffee
yup no none of that none of that
just trying to convince people i have
emotions um that's how it works
well it's working mildly i
i've always told you troy thinks of you
as the quintessential human yeah
it gathered in this galaxy this was
almost
very good nice my face of conclusion
that that was the
that was the one and a quarter speed
version though
on youtube of all the souls what was i
can't remember what the actual line was
i saw that [ __ ] in the theater y'all i
think it's souls wow you remember the
theater
i do there's a place where the biggest
people yell it tell us about tell us
about the theater troy
ah the theater the theater mike
he means the west end he saw he saw a
search for spa or he saw wrath of khan
at the west end
that was the original
originated the role there was the double
billing with like hamlet's first
performance
hey how did you guys feel about uh kong
v godzilla
yeah you know i
i i yeah i didn't become someone it
really
he's gonna do everything so that but i
loft every time a human said anything
because they have to say such ridiculous
[ __ ] they're like
oh no kong's gonna be mad but it's like
something like that that's just cut that
they have to
really believe this stupid [ __ ] they're
saying and i love
it the check probably helps right like
as an actor i'm sure you go
to the yeah go to those gigs and you
take the check and you
you do the job yeah what happened with
brian cranston last time it was like
breaking bad amity ward winning emini
award winning holy crap
to like you're gonna pay me how much for
how little screen time is like
i think he was in five minutes of that
movie we can get you in and out in a day
he's like and how many dollars
all of them okay yeah what you don't see
is he's also in the lizard suit though
did you know ironically brian cranston
has appeared
as a kaiju on screen are you aware when
it's by fact brian cranston did a bunch
of the voices on the original power
rangers
i'm not making that what brian cranston
like one of his first kids was
a bunch of boys well he would voice the
monsters like all of those silly voices
of the monsters on power rangers
he was i assume one of a cast of a lot
of people but he did a bunch of them
that's why he's in the power rangers
movie
this is the stuff you pick up when
you're working at lion's gate during the
production of uh
power ages checks out the movie it makes
sense but like it's true yeah though he
was in he was so he has always decided
there you go
that's amazing it's so great i remember
someone saying to him he's like did you
do
breaking bad because the money he was
like i could have bought an island
after malcolm in the middle i didn't
have to do it no because that's where
the tv money is is from
the the sitcoms it's the malcolm in the
middle it's not the breaking bad
they were like the most high highest
paid actors
i saw that i saw a syndication baby i
thought i thought yeah
the cast of friends the six of them i
think it i think i read that they
today in 2021 they they're making it was
like
10 10 to 20 million a year in their
friends royalties
now today
agencies in america they exist entirely
because of shows like that
there's the one talent agency that's
like got the friends residuals
and the er residuals and that's that was
like the foundation of their company
basically
hey cute sweater but i do you lifted
your almost all right isn't it i quite
like it
i got my
troy is calling in from a secret
location none of us know where i'm
actually underwater james cameron let me
into this by how many fish you [ __ ]
look
all of them yes i want you to know that
i'm i'm looking up i'm fact checking
this power rangers claim
it's bollocks is it do i make it up the
thing is he just has so many credits
it's just taking me forever to scroll
through them all um
um right now that's weird it's a bold
move
go for it that's that you doing that is
weirder than me saying that i might
[ __ ] fish but go ahead
no i'm with you on that um hi everyone
welcome to another episode of play watch
listen
i'm alana that's troy baker who might
[ __ ] a fish that's our friend steven
and that's mike bithell who's wearing a
cool jumper
nuts to be clear i would not [ __ ] a fish
i feel the need to
i want to jump in there and clarify that
what kind of
fish um i did want to say
troy i assume that you've seen today
uh someone aggregated that the last of
us part two
has won more game of the year awards
than any other game ever
did you see that i did not see it yeah
but i'm not surprised
what is it 11 no it's more than that
when when you go across all of the sites
that were available
um it's an absurd amount uh
which means that it just took over the
witcher 3 which was the previous winner
did the witcher 3 hold that before
yeah apparently what did you say the
number was we didn't
another episode when we don't source
things properly
the journalistic standards of this show
is slipping i like it
we saw your logan's run jewel that
you've clearly recently removed wow what
a pool
that's a weird talk i i will say this
but jumping straight into
my stream my my um i'm gonna cut you off
there because
you're right twin man and snizzard
both voiced by brian cranston there's
two episode
uh there's two episode credits
ironically both with the
asterisks of uncredited uh which
probably means he's in more than these
two episodes and these are the only ones
that have been confirmed with by the
by the people at 3am on imdb but here's
what i love
uh episode season 1 episode 14
the voice of scissored and then season
one
episode 38. how many [ __ ] episodes
did they do per season
you know well you know how they did it
you know it was incredibly cheaply
produced because
they basically took a bunch of like
stock footage from japan right you know
the whole
process of how that was produced that
show uh yes
originally it was basically but i did
not know this entirely
um re-cycled and they shot some
things but it was mostly basically shot
like high school movie bits and puts
so i imagine you would be able to make
like 40 episodes anyway yes they took a
they bought the rights to
uh to a japanese show like a superhero
show from japan
and they uh they they you know put it in
a high school setting and used all those
clips the genius thing though and the
thing they got really lucky on
was that that show that they were taking
the footage from had a bunch of sequels
in japan
so every time power rangers costumes
reboots that's them buying up the
footage from a different
new show from japan that's like a cpa
series for the first one yeah
they made enough money that they kept
going yeah again
there's a cartoon that that doesn't mean
it's just entirely read dub i think it's
um oh the anime yes you're right with a
little robot not thinking of the anime
i'm thinking of the
i think it's from the people who made
archer it's it's it's underwater
they're in sea lab maybe c lab
c labs like 2000 or something like 2020
2020 yeah it's 20 21 for the record
season using old animation and the same
characters from hannah barbara's c-lab
2020
all the crew members aboard this sealab
submarine have gone insane so it used
all animation from the
yeah that's what space ghost did space
ghost coast to coast was the first
like i grew up on those uh hannah
barbara cartoons and just all of the
weird crazy ones that they had and it
was just this amalgamation of
uh i got to la right after joe barbera
died
and people still talked about like going
to that studio i was like are you
kidding me that would be like meeting
mel blank for me
it's it's insane um but i i also know
several people that worked on like
og power rangers
that was a grind man there was it was
like 18-hour days
it was no stunt bumps it was it was done
and you're grateful because you got to
be in a show like you got paid but
although isn't that show famously cursed
that basically every cast member has
had horrible fates befall them over the
years
i mean power rangers people that have
like isn't it
famously that like half of them are dead
and and it's like just a
show of horrible like if you read about
every of them are dead
but i definitely know that it's it's
that there's there's been a lot of
disproportionately tragic written cast
uh i thought you're talking about
there's there's another show that
makes me suspicious of crap to be honest
it's true he was the one he was the one
who knocked very early
cranston definitely like got a good part
of the deal
um to answer your burning question
it was 261 game of the year once what
we're having three conversations at once
are there that many games websites this
is the best like overlap
we've we've gone from crosstalk to
subjects we are a bioware dialogue tree
randomly but you come back and then
until you say i don't want to talk to
you anymore but yeah um this is
on vg247 the ps4 exclusive was given
261 game of the year awards
uh meaning it now has more game of the
year awards than any other release ever
which
probably makes it a bit of a difficult
metric when it comes to overtaking the
witcher because there would be more
websites now than there were
unless they averaged it um yeah we need
to like adjust your website inflation
uh no it's not that old you're right
it's not what is it 2014. it's not like
at the dawn of media journalism can we
agree that it's a
silly metric but it's still very
impressive and awesome and congrats to
the team
yeah and i what i was going to say was
kind of
zoning into my my little lane here the
thing that i really commend
dice or ais for for doing is that the
category
that they choose to nominate for the
participation of
of actors if that that scans is the
outstanding achievement
in character yeah which to me is just
far more accurate
and apt because it's not just the
performance the performance could be one
thing but
there's so much that goes does that
encompass like the animation
team and the it does oh cool that's
great yeah and the right
it's the modeling and the writing it's
and the writing it's like how is that
character
what was the level of impact or what was
the thing that they achieved most
it's outstanding achievement that's cool
so it's not even based necessarily
oh i had that one scene that made me cry
it's about
this character achieved greatness
we feel more than any other this year
that to me is one of the best ways to
put it it's
it's so even keel and and
really brings in the team yeah more than
anything else
he focuses on the character not just the
actor i
to that end and in that category big
shout out to
my friend darren corb who exactly is not
nominated for the music of hades sort of
surprisingly
um in at dice but is nominated
as his as the voice actor of zagreus for
hades which i
i just have no idea i'm like he's yeah
he's nominated against ashley and laura
uh and i texted him and i was like
um what did i say uh
i i i send him i troll him with stupid
videos and i said i don't care if you're
now competing for top
honors as an actor in games i'm still
sending you
videos of mike me making coffee how does
he feel about it
he says i think i can rationalize this
specifically because it's achievement in
character
and greg is credited for the writing and
i said well i don't care i still look
forward to your ascendance to hysterical
arrogance
this year is also obviously fully
virtual
taking place in april um rather than
february
yeah april that's weird yeah it feels
really strange and i was just thinking
about it was like the last time that i
went to any event which i imagine was
probably the same for you guys
was dice that's the last time i went
somewhere and saw people
um so it was that photo office right
yeah all four of us were there right
which we really would have thought we'd
do again oh my god that was last year
a year ago yeah yeah a whole year ago
because
i presented when you and and you did as
well troy right you presented well did
you pick one up
you presented one troy presented music
yeah
judith and then austin i think he
presented the year before
yeah i presented music the year before i
got to i got to give pete scoturo on
behalf of
he and bear mccrary the award for god of
war and
last year the winner was
what goose game won most stuff that was
control it was crucial
yeah i feel like um i kind of wanted to
ask this
troy because like i know people have
worked on
games that launched in 2020
and the fact that they don't get to do
the press tours and the parties
was a real bummer for a lot of those
people to work on something for such a
long time and then not have the
events and the excitement in a
public-facing way was a real bummer do
you feel that way
with the last of us part two like is it
is it a bummer that you didn't get to
you know receive one of 261
awards or at least be there when they're
presented in person or does it not
have a profound impact so
i i i've thought the same thing
because when we first started doing this
um
[Music]
there was a huge event that i i didn't
go to
in london for the last of us part one
and ashley and i have done
multiple press junkets i'm in london
we've done it in new york in la
and it is fun to kind of watch the
anticipation
it's it's almost like you know the kid
going over to the christmas tree and
they pick up
or your friend or whatever you pick up
the the one present that you know is the
big present
and they just kind of like wonder what's
in here and you like you know
and just to see them try to figure out
and shake the box a little bit
that to me was those those press tours
when they when they get enough of they
know that a president is coming but they
don't know what's inside of it but you
do
um that's a real joy and it's also a
great moment
when because those pr those parties
happen um when the game is done
you know it's like everyone else is just
kind of hands up on the ride
and we've done multiple one there was
the great one for uncharted that we got
to do in a medieval castle in rome
outside of rome
um i've done one for second son that was
literally we hit
we did paris rome london
in like as many days like as many cities
as we did days and
those are those are so much fun um and
it's a great celebration
i picture the second sun after party as
being marked by fully destructible
environment
dude it was what what each city did that
was bespoke to the city was was dope
we done it for arkham origins where
roger and i got to go to london it's
like
they've been incredible once that we've
done and it's something that i was
really looking forward to doing for the
last of us part two because
you would have to include the three of
us because otherwise you would tip the
hat
you know and so it was like this is what
we have to do it's gonna be joel
it's gonna be ellie and it's gonna be
abby um and being able to have that
and people looking back on it later and
asking questions everything it's just a
fun fun thing to do and it's a great
um celebratory time but
we would have literally been in front of
press
the hour that the leaks broke
hmm that wouldn't have been fun that
would not have been a great experience
so we would have been
you would have just been western i was
going to say they would have just
pulled it right they would they wouldn't
have even attempted everything
and but there would have still been that
weird awkward thing and it's like
we need you guys to stay in your hotel
rooms and we're canceling rome and we're
canceling
like they were going to do a big long
press tour
and i have no idea what the actual
extent of it was but i do know this is
it possible that naughty dog
leaked the coronavirus to get out in
front
of the
i i can't wait for the color bars to
come back
i'm like upset with you for that one i
was just like no i'm not even responding
to that
that's the gift for this episode it's
just all of us like what i love is that
what that means alana is that you felt
nothing but you projected exactly yeah
you created the illusion pointing out
yeah and my poor taste oh i know what
day mike bithell has had
because i'm drinking a pepsi i've had a
tough one yeah it's been a busy one
today yeah yeah
you're all right no i'm great yeah i'm
good i'm good just knackered all right
mike
can't complain you know how it is all
right absolutely
no i i appreciate you asking that but it
is it is definitely and dice is the one
like last year was
was such a fun time because it was the
first time that i
i went not being just like a party goer
and that's what i'd always done with
dice before is just and it's the
beautiful people at iis that were like
hey man if you really want to know about
this industry if you really want to
operate in this industry
you need to just you need to come for
more than just the after party
there's a lot of it was such a beautiful
cross-section of the industry
and watching how that worked and just it
was it was such a beautiful time and
it's it's it's the one that i i've never
been to gdc
and and austin i know for you that is
like
that's my summer camp summer camp for
you special
um that was like spring break you know
what i mean
it wasn't summer camp but it was spring
break um so it's something that i
definitely uh i'm gonna miss
miss this year but and it's weird
because they're falling right in the
bathtub window right
because that's bafta is literally that
that i think even that day isn't bafta
a little a little earlier or is that the
same thing
like that first week of april let me
google it
okay i i do
i will say i will say that that
um you know alana your question was
about attending
all the award shows and stuff and but i
think the related question that troy you
kind of
sidelined into is launch parties
yeah i mean you would have that for the
apocalypse that's the thing our launch
party for the pathless was a zoom call
where we all ordered lunch independently
and
and and just hung out yeah cause like
people and there were some remote team
members that
were able to be there that may not have
but it's definitely
for me launch parties have always been
one of them
the best parts it's like going to the
premiere when you work on a movie
where it's for it's for the people who
made it
it's for like if you watch hollywood
press coverage you get the impression
that premieres are all about the red
carpet and the celebrities but the
reality is it's for the crew
above all it's for the people that put
in the thousand hours over however
minute however much time and i feel like
launch parties
get that more directly than like a movie
premiere because there's
not usually much of a public in fact so
much of the game is still probably
unannounced in many cases
depending on when they do the launch
party that it really is
just kind of a closed door bring your
friends bring your family
bring your kids whatever and like let's
just
raise a glass to what you have all just
done and especially when it's before
reviews have hit or anything and so it's
still just
turbocharged with that optimism of like
we think we hope we've made something
really special
no one's dragged us through the mud uh
it's
that to me is the real tragedy of all
these great games
you know ghosts of tsushima hades um
and then you know the smaller the
smaller games that have gotten the
spotlight of
you know like like spirit fairer or or
or
you know petrie's game nueta or or like
anything
solitary conspiracy that like we're
getting into super technical that wasn't
about launch party either way
to be honest that wouldn't have got a
launch fire though wait four months if
we've got a launch mcdonald's
chips down i actually did go so you know
what's weird that was the first time we
won so genuinely
we normally do gather for like the
launch of a game and it was that solid
experience was the first time we've ever
launched a game where
with the the kind of the core team
weren't in the same place
that is weird because normally we all
order pizza and sit in the same room at
least yeah you always said you didn't
have sacred tradition champagne and
pizza or whatever that you do champagne
and pizza
that is the tradition the most expensive
wine we can afford and the cheapest
pizza we can find
combine the two and that's your evening
yeah that's the those rituals really
mean something yeah they do
yeah they do they really do mentally
look i always want to say when we have
any kind of
conversation about this there are people
who have it way worse than us like
always feel like i need to acknowledge
the tremendous privilege that we have to
still have jobs you know but um
there are definitely things that that
come with this
that i feel like like letting go of a
project like feeling like it's
done is like a thing that you kind of
have to readjust to when you don't have
the rituals that you're used to having
anymore and it's all just
you know in the same room like i left a
job and then started at a new company
and usually that would be like you'd
have your going away thing and i just
haven't seen any of those people since i
left i think i saw them once
and then you have your joining the new
place thing
and you don't get anything for that it's
it's just transitions are just really
weird and i was thinking like
particularly with the last of us part
two
i feel like it's still difficult to talk
about that game like that hasn't died
down like people are still really
opinionated
and it was just a thought that occurred
to me that was like a lot of people
really love that game
and i think when you're on the internet
because i remember enjoying paxis for
this reason you can feel like people are
so negative and then
i'd like go to a pax and i walk in and
people are really nice and you're like
i need this refresher of how nice people
actually are outside of the internet
and i feel like like just you know
people talking about that game in person
would probably be a very nice thing to
have where
sometimes it feels like it's so so
vitrolic it's just it's just a bummer
we're just abominated
just across the gla global scale really
global bomber
what i'm going to say of 2020 it's just
not the greatest of times is it no it's
not
no it's not the worst of times not the
best of times it does seem
to be showing signs on the ascendance
out of the worst of it though
uh i do think that there are there are
glimmers of optimism plus i actually saw
a really heartening video
of a guy in the in the spirit of like uh
it wasn't stephen pinker but it was
someone of a similar kind of
uh style you know the stephen pinker who
who
has written a handful of books but his
the line he's constantly
uh parading around is is that by
basically every
objective metric that you could analyze
this through we are living in
far and away the best time in all of
human history
you know it but and there's just a
million different lenses through which
to view that whether it's poverty rates
or
or food insecurity and starvation
penicillin and violent crime rates but
yeah like
excellence
i mean probably probably historically
that's probably true
yeah on a saturday night i love to kick
back but it passed away
so people just said somebody just used
to get a cut and then they would die
you know like penicillin really changed
a lot for us
there's there's there's there's a whole
list and and somebody was saying i've
never used those antibiotics
gary got cut it's been nice knowing you
gary you've got penicillin yeah
maybe next year just follow me to the
river you look at um
warfare like basically until the 20th
century
the majority of yeah we were really bad
and now we're really good at that
fair enough our weapons weigh spears
[ __ ] to people
but the thing is what i was going to say
is that that's not what would kill you
that's the thing like it was the
infections afterwards i know it was far
more lethal like in the civil war
you know vast amounts of these soldiers
dying were not
the u.s civil war i should clarify it's
not that
the the the chunk of lead lodged in
their arm
killed them it was the fact that they
had no reasonable ability short of
amputation and even then that may not be
enough
uh and so they would just die this
horrendous slow
death uh from a from a wound that today
you know the er would have sorted it'd
be it'd be an awful experience but you
wouldn't
be at risk of dying in 99 of the cases
from that i mean
the point that they were making was just
i was going to say i had to deal with
most of my stupid wounds at home
obviously my hands are healed over a lot
of hurt
stupid stupid wounds my knees still a
wound
but all that stuff i was able to do from
home because there's peroxide spray
and there are just a million different
things that i was told to put on my skin
that's like this will kill germs you use
this one to numb yourself
this one will help with this thing this
one will give you moisture when they're
back at a point where they're kind of
closed like there were so many different
things that it was so easy to get to
just be like okay i know what i have to
do for this
whereas previously you hurt your knee
like that my knee was
was a pretty big wound and it's like you
ski
and then you just get sick you gotta
cough in a couple of days like it's just
made a lot of progress there how do we
get here and and the point being that
of all the time periods in human history
and if you could p if you had to pick
a time for a coronavirus pandemic you
would pick
2020 is the point they were making which
was not a way of thinking about it that
i had thought of
and i found that i found that very
heartening it was like
this thing would think about how much
more devastating it would have been
30 years ago or 50 years ago like like
there have been plenty of pandemics
um but in a modern era of plane travel
and things like that that facilitate
this thing moving around which obviously
you know the
spanish flu pandemic that was probably
one of the saving graces of it was that
global travel was a fraction of what it
it would be today
but so if this had been like 1970 where
global travel was
you know a lot closer to today but
without any of the treatment
and ventilators and all manner of
you know i mean it's just like it it's
like it's as
horrible as it was there actually was an
upside way to look at it and say
it it you know it it's the classic
optimus pass you would always
be worse to be you know yes it can
furthest
in the future that's my point of
speaking as as vitriolic as it was for
the last of us when it came out
i can't imagine that's how we got here
yeah that's a segway
i can't imagine being in this i would
have been at
cons i would have been sat
in front of fans where people were
it was a pressure cooker right people
were
the the the situation as it stood
there was uncertainty with kovid there
was this
game that was seemingly divisive
and people weren't happy
and to be in that situation who knows
what could have happened and i am an
avatar
for all of it because i'm out in front
and i'm known for it same thing would
have gone for ashley or laura
or anybody who is a part of that game
and so i look at this as man if ever
there was a
um
a illustration for the notion that there
is no good there is no bad only thinking
makes it so and it's simply our
perspective that can choose whether
something is quote good or bad
i look at that and go man that's
protection and
i look at all of the things this is
coming full circle from when we started
talking about quarantine the power
rangers oh i
yeah power rangers too cranston um brian
crudson who said
the the notion that like
there there has been an uptick in um
this has created some industry this has
created some jobs it's also
i just i can't think about any of the
stuff like that man even last night pam
and i were sitting in bed and i'm like
i'm really overwhelmed i'm just thinking
about
all the things that we want to
accomplish and all the things that i
didn't have as a kid
that i want to be able to provide for
for traveler and if
i won't feel like a failure but i do
feel like the onus is on me to be able
to provide for him a life that i didn't
have and it's not vicarious
but it's just i want to be able if i
will do better
one better than what i had i've at least
moved the needle forward and i've i've
done better
so it but there's a tremendous amount of
pressure that that goes along with that
but being able to go i was i was
drifting away from
from from traveler man and because
i tried to help a lot and i was busy and
i was traveling and it was easy for me
to go i've got to go be busy right now
and he and i just weren't hanging we are
[ __ ]
locked that is my dude and
i look at this and i go it's not well i
guess there's some good that comes with
the bad it's being able to look at the
situation and go
because of this i will make this there's
a poem that was written this morning
it's being able to see the sun in the
midst of the rain and scoop a
cool hand of water in the midst of the
raging fire
and that notion of like i understand
that there is some good that will come
from this
just as much as there will also be some
bad that comes from this
yeah even when you're in again
situations much worse than ours where we
are employed
you have a house you have a family uh i
think it's something that no matter who
you are
or what position you're in if there is
always value in looking for the positive
obviously that can be extremely hard to
do but that's where i think video games
helped a lot of people
uh in 2020 as well it's just something
about the the dice
nominees being listed made me more
reflective than any other moment because
i feel like dice is like the awards show
that i
i really like tail my year with every
year like it being february
it's the time where i see everyone and
then you know it's like immediately end
of e3 usually it's like something about
that event was really significant to me
i was just thinking about
you know it being tough for a lot of
studios who didn't get to
to celebrate the way they normally would
same applies to fans
um i was going to say before the last
event that i actually went to was the
launch party ferrari in the world of the
wisps which was the game came out on
march 11.
it was like right then um
and i left early when they when they
opened it up to more people because it
was still like the
idea of covert was something that we
were aware of but not terrified of
at that point i think um and the dev
team was there and
they were talking about how a lot of
them got pulled so a lot of them weren't
allowed to go to their own launch party
and they were really bummed like they
had to be selective about who could go
and who couldn't and how much of a
bummer that is and
obviously the industry's adapted and in
some ways succeeded tremendously like
animal crossing
i put so much time into that game i
bought my sister
a switch for her birthday and we hung
out on christmas day
on my animal crossing island and that
was really nice as a thing that
you can't really do without video games
they
even among us you know that's a game
that came out two years ago but i'm
playing it socially all the time
it's like such a relief which i feel
like
credit to video games where credit is
due they did a lot of good last year for
a lot of people and
i think animal crossing inherited the
absolute quintessential right place at
the right time dumb
luck like of the millennium just
exactly what people needed and wanted
from a game and to for a game to be like
this source of
catharsis and community far and away
beyond what
i'm sure they were even imagining and
intending and oh yeah you know they like
sold way better than they produced and
true escapism like in the best way like
in a therapeutic way
yeah oh exactly that that same week of
of
of dice you know um for me it i
understand the notion of like
in rapping out the year because there's
like so much stuff that happens
like of all these games that launch you
have all the awards shows that happen
then like february is kind of like
to me it was the beginning of a new
cycle me too it's like
here we go no january we're starting out
here yeah
it's for me it's not january that a new
year starts it's dice every time
yeah yeah exactly that that's exactly
what the notion for me was
and i did i was in vegas for two weeks
because i did a con and it's too long
that's a choice
that is a choice um
by myself and then i did a con and like
in between them like pam and traveler
came and we got to hang out and stuff
and
seeing the coolest thing is like trevor
looking at fountains and and hearing
beetles just like this is awesome i'm
like
okay vegas could be kind of cool but
then literally going
right from there that that con was the
last one that i did so it went dice con
fly back to la the next day or maybe
even that night
fly to london to go to kuwait yeah
that's right i remember that because i
got stuck in l.a
yeah what sucks is that i was on the
plane
with um uh gus fring
uh yes yes you've definitely told this
story before and i remember it but
we'll let you retell it because i don't
remember it distinctly
it's still cool though
and i was like hey man we have the same
manager we just got i just got a text
from him it's like the kuwait show is
off and he was like what i was like yeah
man
so we ended up hanging out in the la or
the the london airport for a second and
if i had known at that time
like literally two weeks later they
announced that he was in far cry i was
like oh we could have so much
far cry stories um i would have only
asked him mandalorian stories
please tell me where you should get upon
as a guest we should get all those
guests just for about laura can you hit
your manager up and see if he wants to
come talk about medical
hit that up done
we were also supposed to go to um
emerald city comic con which is uh
always um i've had some great memories
at that show and
yeah three days before we were supposed
to go they're like the show's done
so that this time of year this was
someone was telling me about the french
festival in adelaide
and how a year ago
it was the last time we were like i'm
not sure what's gonna happen
and then they go through this entire
year and
they're now putting up battle signs in
adelaide going we're back guys we're
going to be able to do this french fest
and that to me new zealand posting
pictures today was like
what happened tripod pals have been
doing gigs yeah they've been telling me
they're like doing shows
the city of perth in australia i think
hasn't had any cases in like over 200
days
um because it was australia day
yesterday which problematic
but um that meant that there are uh
nationwide celebrations
and it's just people walking around with
no mosques it helps that perth is ten
thousand miles away from anything it's
super isolated
five million people in new zealand but
the main thing is
don't politicize it don't argue with it
it's just uncomfortable are you talking
about the last of us
being taken away just wear a mask
and stay away from it and let the girls
kiss a little bit
i don't think troy heard me which makes
that just just the most perfect
confusion
cool cool
you know they're they're okay in that
video again i just loved i loved that so
much
cool fully endorsed everything that you
just said my friend cool
douchebag that really was i think my
favorite 10 seconds that was really good
yeah i also love all the comments that
are like poor troy has told that
uncharted story
20 times and they just don't remember it
each time
i genuinely don't remember you telling
that two prior times no i don't know
that's possible i mean you know which
uncharted story will you just tell the
story about that
i don't know the hijacking story yeah
i don't remember telling that story it's
not y'all's fault it's mine i think
we're being gaslight by our comments
am i allowed to tell them i think that's
it here's the deal the whole
shipment of what
i'm not going to do we didn't get to
hear mike explain
i actually genuinely want to hear you
mike unpack this but i suppose we're
probably running out of time now
uh of the whole game demo discussion
that we just sort of blew right by
and i know that's a total about face and
has nothing to do with anything we're
talking about at this point and probably
worth revisiting later but it's all
right it is a really interesting
question
because to me i realized that the the
economic
it probably comes down to the economics
of are you better off shipping a game
and having a
liberal refund policy or offering a free
demo up front i miss demos man oh you
mean like a demo
you mean like a player i thought you
meant um like the
is that actually like um i assume that's
no i think i meant the i mean like the
game demo
like an e3 or what what what was what
was the game we were talking about the
one you're in troy the
two worlds uh medium i i actually just
got it
yeah we were talking about that right
the video yeah yeah cool
so so am i confused about the premise of
the question
i wouldn't say confusion i think i was
talking about something else but that's
that's also an interesting question
against the previous of the question
for the i definitely do want to talk
about game demos and previews because i
realized especially with all the
cyberpunk stuff that
i think that people think that and i
think this is an issue that the press
has not
more explicitly expressed what they are
but i think that the press thinks that
a preview is the game rather than a
preview being
basically a mini entirely separate game
that functions as a little build by
itself heavily orchestrated
so as to avoid all the problems people
are going to hit launch yeah
yeah and i think that that's a thing
that like when you know some of the
cyberpunk conversation came out that a
realization i had was like
i don't think in all of my time in media
that's something we know but it's not
something that we ever say
we we're just like it's a preview build
this is not a product but it's so much
like it is literally not the game it is
a
separate video game and i don't think
that's been explained also you're
actively being generous to it like i've
never had a negative preview right like
it's really hard to write a negative
generally because why would you right
because you know it's a work in progress
you can i often with previews you'll see
the writer is kind of pointing out like
some of the areas they want to see more
because none of it's something lacking
but usually it feels like they hand you
the thing that is the best on the silver
platter
and then you walk away and you it's
supposed to be indicative of the game
so if if you feel like it didn't tick
the boxes
i don't think that's because it didn't
communicate to what the mechanic the
core mechanics are going to be if you
if it didn't uh show to you what the
story is like how how do you grade
god this is a whole other yeah i feel
like this is like we could have a full
podcast
that's another episode yes episode i
only want to do it because that one's so
audience has been with us long enough to
know that we'll have forgotten about
this before the next episode yeah we
never did our last it was part 2 spoiler
class mike did you ever go back
never went back i need to i still need
to i still need to
i do believe if they follow suit i do
not know that they're going to do this
but if they follow suit with what they
did last
time yeah i'll bring it to ps5
um i'll be curious i'll go back i think
that'll be just enough time people like
i played it 17 times i'm like that's not
me i love
you great i love that game i love those
characters
it is not there are certain movies that
if they are on i will watch
and then there's others that are like
i'm going to watch that once every two
years um
like goodfellas is a movie like that
where it's like nah you gotta you gotta
you gotta sit down and watch that movie
uh the last of us part two will be that
for me that's not a movie that i wanna
continually just go back and play the
thing about the last part two for me i
think
is that because of the context of that
game not the social context like the
literal in-game
context i think that if i play that game
again which i probably will
that my brain will so strongly associate
associated with 2020
will be like pandemic that was when i
was indoors
that was when my life felt like
everything was dragging really slowly
and i was in a terrible place and a lot
of people were
or are you doing that already right
like you said over the holiday break you
paid a lot of 90s movies
or playing a lot of 90s games because
that to you was like
um yeah gimmick of the holidays yeah
because i've always played like retro
games with my sister every
every christmas really but chicken soup
for you yeah i guess
yeah i mean that's why i stopped playing
it wasn't that i hated it it was that
i just hadn't it's a real stress on tv
all the time
and i found that i don't need that i
want to go back to it once i'm happy
basically once once the world's a little
bit better i will 100
i'm ready to be crushed again yeah no
crush me crush me more being
being a deeply empathetic game a deeply
empathetic person
that game is is a slugfest oh yeah uh
intentional yeah punches you in the face
oh yeah intentionally yeah absolutely
yeah it's it's rough i i cried multiple
times and
and that's like but was it all at your
own scenes
was it was it was it when you appeared
on screen now okay
we all made the same joke one of the
most impactful scenes if you needed
a matter of fact i did i did this for
someone i showed them one scene
that they had no idea about the last of
us at all
and they were kind of not not in a
disparaging way but they're just kind of
like
look i know movies and this is this is a
someone who's very
skilled and familiar with that industry
but doesn't think that games can do that
i was like i want to show you one scene
and i showed them the scene at the farm
so it had nothing to do with me i was
like if i want to show you i could sit
here and try to see if
i could impress you with my skills and
show you hey that's me
but i was like if you really want to see
true incredible performances
writing having no idea of the world the
story or the characters
i can show you that scene between ellie
and tommy
yeah and dina yeah and go that
and it was like well wait a minute it
was compelling and that's when i knew
that scene stands alone as a piece of
art period
you would have a better read on this
than i mean any of us
um do you think that people were able to
play the loss of his part two without
having to play the first game
completely fine i imagine they were
yeah i feel like this i mean it was
structured to
to be that way like they they were very
we we wrote scenes specific for that
that and
there's so much stuff that happens in
the world that informs you there's a lot
of people that
that i've heard anecdotally that went
back and played
one because they never played it i mean
look think about it there's people that
were
eight years old that are playing games
now exactly that they're like last of us
what you mean part two they just have no
concept like
how the first one works people it's hard
for me
i feel like that game it's so hard for
me to wrap my head around
playing the second one as your first way
into that world because i think it leans
so heavily what works so well about it
is the baked in knowledge you have
of joel and ellie like it lean the more
that you have invested in that the more
that game is going to challenge you
in the best in in like with what's with
its central
with its central it's like seeing you
hope without attack of the clones isn't
it
but absolutely yeah is there not stuff
like
like left behind is a perfect example of
weight being added retroactively to
something
i loved that dude left behind
blew me away yeah i never played it
until beautiful
like day before the last of us two came
out i i was one of those i missed it and
i did a replay of the first one and then
did left behind for the first time and i
was
i was like i can't this is like a
miracle of a dlc
because it's incredible the brilliance
of where it inserts in the story
and and what it shows us of ellie and
this and the choice of
denying us that side of ellie until
after we finished the game i was
it was one of those where i just thought
it's so hard for me to imagine
discovering that opportunity after the
fact and then exploiting it
for a dlc and not thinking of it ahead
of time and doing that on
purpose but it's my understanding is
that is actually what happened like
finish the game and then go okay what
can we do with what we've got and say oh
here could be an interesting opportunity
for a way to
continue the story and it's like i can't
believe that that's insane
it feels so perfect that it's just
impossible for me to imagine
it's like when you watch an amazing tv
show and season five
is paying off things from season one and
you just think
how did they write their way into that
you know how did they how do they
vampire
but the retroactive
empathy that you get from that i feel
like something about
you know playing through the first game
and then playing that and then the
weight that it adds to something you've
already experienced
is very cool and also i think something
that video games can do really well
i like i don't know how many the game
like the whole video game thing
like what that means to her is like oh
my god she's playing the game again
it's just like oh jesus christ i watched
a really
um great video that i don't know it just
showed up in my recommended
i've been watching a lot of like game
maker toolkit
type videos like just a lot of different
channels analyses a video
whatever it's just been my it's been
like my when i walk my dog in the
morning that's been my
my morning i love you soon i watched
people make hands
and like the one behind you and uh
so i um i watched this video a channel
i'd never heard of before called like
stories of old that that
they did a last of us part two video
called the painful art of empathy
and one of the points that he makes in
the video that i thought was really cool
was he said
he played through the game twice and it
was the most
different emotional experiences of a
play through he's ever had in his life
because he said the first play through
he had
all kinds of issues with the game and
was like yeah you know
and he was very much on the side of or i
don't want to speak for him because i'm
probably overstating it but
it was i think tilted on the edge of the
people that were not convinced by the
game that just felt like i
didn't like this i didn't like that
that's a stretch you know not on board
with this
and then something compelled him to play
through it a second time and then sort
of like knowing what he knew playing
through it again
it it wrecked him uh and he still had
critiques and in the video what i like
is that it's not
it's not a frothing here's all the
reasons why this is the best game ever
made
it's it's he he makes pointed
fair criticisms while also explaining
the way in which
the narrative and the mechanics come
together and
uh just the victories that the games the
game achieves
as an entry into the art form of video
games
this is a great example of how critics
work harder than the original artists
oh my god that tweet
[Laughter]
i feel bad for him because it's one of
those things that seems
really clever when you think of it like
7am when you're drinking a cup of coffee
you're like oh i'm going to tweet this
he followed up with don't argue with me
but i famously constantly took the piss
with quotes
that were snowingly stupid i feel sorry
for the guy because the original troll
he keeps being quote tweeted by people
who are not
acknowledging that he apologized and and
was like this is a terrible i'm getting
dunked on and i deserve it that's my bad
i totally screwed up because it's not in
the thread
yeah but i'm like if you're gonna quote
tweet him you gotta at least
do your diligence to add that so he's
not getting a pile on but i can't
believe i should read that tweet for
anyone who hasn't seen it
at this stage i'm just impressed that
he's not deleted like at this point like
he's owned it really well
um yeah it is a it is a systemic
uh architectural problem of twitter i
find that
when the original tweet goes that much
more viral than the follow-up
you will actually have to actively hunt
to see his
it's by design man true it's by design
it's not an accident
you know it's designed to be a fighter i
i think it's i think it's emergent i
think it's it's not a bug it's a feature
but i don't think it's by the way saying
it's a procedurally generated
outcome it's not that it's intentional
so many callbacks
that it's so good it it it is the
algorithm working as it should and that
the thing with the most engagement is
the thing that gets pushed to the top
because it's keeping people on the app
right
like that is the but the design is not
to hurt people
not trying to make you no but it wants
to make you angry and the result of
angry
people is hurt yeah so the guy's name is
jerry saltz
um he is an art creation
it got me to buy that book like i was
like huh i've never read this book i
considered that too
do you think he's an oscar wilde
influencer um
the tweet is a good critic always puts
more into writing about artwork than the
artists put into making it the artist
only creates the critic must plumb that
creation and also write creatively
enough to deliver the full volume of the
art while also creating a thing of
beauty and clarity itself
and as someone who is that's just that's
that that's true
so by definition any quote tweet of that
tweet is better than that it's better
than the original tweet yes
no it uh it is it is absolutely an
absurd thing to say about it basically a
perpetual motion machine
it's amazing we've created it to get
better and better and better about it
which doesn't i have met critics who
unironically believe that right like
there are that is a
perspective i've definitely witnessed
you know
they all need to go watch ratatouille i
think that there
is there is truth or at least
there is some um
validity to the purpose of art is to be
interpreted
it is not art until it is presented to
the world and subjected to their
opinions that is what art
is um and i definitely believe that
art can be extrapolated from
art in the form of an opinion of course
it made me feel this way and to describe
that in such a way
that can be art but it is
yeah but it is wholly separate from
not it is it is not divisible
of it is it is just something that is
completely different it can't say
it's the transitive value aspect of the
statement that protects well yeah it's
that the critic puts more into than the
artist put into making it and i think it
really took off with people in the games
industry because they're like
you're telling me i spent five years
making this [ __ ] thing
and when i've written a review 30
minutes while you were taking your shoes
well okay the harder
reviews are a little bit harder than
that okay it's not
that simple all of them that's true but
like you might not know them sometimes
you know two week process it's still
that two weeks is not
five years
i don't think i've ever written here
i was going to say troy you need to make
a youtube channel of you
in like an outhouse and it's like 30
minutes to review
yeah welcome to troy's reviews while
taking his [ __ ] today we talk about
hitman 3.
i don't understand what i'm doing i got
to kill a guy i don't got to kill a guy
wear his clothes nobody knows about
that's my review he's made better by the
fish
talk about the game not talking about
the writer but when the the
creative director of the studio one of
the senior managers of the studio gets a
call from a very prominent
news or media outlet they're like hey i
don't have time to play
your review but we got to go to press
can you do me a favor and just walk me
through
the mechanics and the story of the game
someone called someone and asked if they
could just write a review based on an
explanation
yes and so again he went sure i'd love
to and he walked in the public knowledge
is this is this is this that was there
seven out of ten though that's the thing
right that's the sticker
i'd i'd stay on the phone for an a6 or
sorry it was even less than that
it was like wait a minute i do it i do
it and they have the audacity to do this
and
wrote this piece about it i forget that
in triple-a and 86 is a bad review score
sorry
yeah it wasn't even that like it was it
was low like they they maligned the game
it was like you didn't even play it
and it literally was a 30 minute phone
call
and it's like hey [ __ ] there's
people's jobs at stake
that is absurd again i will repeat the
thing that i've said before and that it
is not the reviewer's
job to think about the people's jobs who
are at stake
it is the reviewer's job to play the
[ __ ] thing they're reviewing though
that is objectively there
no no no no no no no their betrayal
they need to think if i say this
and there's there's consequences to my
actions that's the problem
is that there's no bridle when people
just write whatever they want it's the
free and the hide behind the first
amendment saying i can say whatever i
want it's like yeah but you have
consequences to your actions
but they're not responsible for the
developers problems
oh and by the way if you say this we
have to terminate you but what i am
saying is
understanding that there's a
journalistic responsibility and when i
say
this is terrible if you say that the
purpose of the media
is for the consumer and it's not for the
developer
it is to inform the public and you go by
the way
it is horrifically racist and they do
all of these things so like
nobody did was like well i didn't play
the game but i just heard that yesterday
but that happened that's insane
i would not that's what i'm saying is
like you do have a journalistic
responsibility to be able to go well
before i say this
i should play the game and understand
that whatever i write there will be
consequences to that
yeah i agree with that i do agree with
that i i just fight against
the the idea that it would be the
journalist's job to think about um
a publisher's shitty practices like your
bonuses tied to your review score
journalists can't
think about that kind of thing because
then everything just it all becomes
pointless like 100 pointless
yeah it'd be like us like worrying about
the journalists in the process of making
the game which would be equally
silly yeah but so you can you you choose
the context
no i'm just saying it can't be a
journalist's responsibility
to consider the publisher's shady
business practices
that's not a shady business practice a
bonus title trying bonuses for review
scores
look we can we could i would say less
than pleasant
i think i think that there is there's
some
there's smarter brains than i i'm not
saying that it's a great thing but
there's metrics that are discovered
through the process of experiencing
conversations to be able to go look
we want to give you a bonus we have to
make it triggerable by something
and it's like well what if we do we what
if we make our street date great we'll
give you a bonus for that
so that's a conversation between the
developer and the publisher whether
people think it's shady or not that's
between the publisher the developer i
have no idea and
or stake in that but if there is a not
there is
the developers do though sorry to be a
dick about it but the developers have a
mistake in that literally
if their bonus is tied to review scores
then ultimately
the problem with it is the a review
score well first of all a metacritic
score is obviously only a cumulative of
like
x number of players so there's a
limitation there b
review scores are often directly or
indirectly
uh based on the marketing of the game
the
actual the ability of the game to get
into journalists hands not in a shady
you can guess what they're doing
expectations based right yeah and that
means that that's not a good metric to
gauge whether
joe blogs in the animation department
did a good job plus also
that's that's my biggest problem i agree
with that
but but again it's not up to me to
decide i just simply think it's like
whether it's a shitty system or not
if you say i understand what good design
is i understand what good
audio is i understand what good
performance is as i understand what good
art is i understand what all of these
good things
is contextually within the industry and
you go by the way
based on this context this is my score
but i understand that if i say
this thing is a 65 then that is going to
have an impact you do have a
responsibility to that
you should take into account and go look
you should take it seriously
but you can't be sweaty seriously but if
you yeah
if they got paid to give lower scores
they would
if the games are sixty-five and they're
good they should give it a 65.
you're talking about incentives from
like the igns
and kotaku's of the world and they're
talking i think you're talking past each
other because
okay alana is saying i love this
conversation it would be it would be
wrong to give a low score to give an
artificially high score to prevent a
publisher from laying off people or
holding back bonuses or whatever and
like that's not your job to worry about
that
yeah no i i i hear that
no no one's talking about like bonuses
for for
uh giving saying because it's like
clickbait or something
proving well proving the point
that there's there's that's a double
blade right
that while it's not my job i was like
i'm just going to grade it on a curve
because i like them
i don't think you should do that i think
but i do believe that there is a
journalistic responsibility going
75 because we need to get clicks
or just because i thought so if it's not
i mean it sounds like you're basically
just because i thought so it's fine
isn't it just because i thought so is
fine
like if it's if it's because that's
their opinion of what the game is i
would say
uh in my experience for i don't know the
30 outlets that i wrote for
journalists all hate giving scores but i
would also say it's
not flippant that it is a thing that
multiple people even review like usually
you
you se you write your review and then
you give your score and then people will
be like
here's why it does or your what you've
written does or does not align with this
number like
it reads higher it reads lower and that
is that is a discussion i do think
people take it pretty seriously
it sucks like i feel like a troy was a
perfect example of this
death training was like zero you're like
come on you know
yeah that's ridiculous that has an
impact on on something so it's
it's the it's the understanding of
when i press send and this goes
out this is going to have a ripple
effect
and that there should be some it's the
same thing as like
being able to cite sources and and being
able to
not just say whatever you want even
though it's an op-ed
understanding how news is is consumed by
the consumer and that people will take
that as truth there's there's a level of
i feel like troy
we could just possibility we could just
summarize this as basically don't be a
crappy
reviewer like i feel like everything
you're describing is just
would be a would be them fundamentally
not doing the job as it theoretically
ought to be done
there will also be reviews as well that
fall outside the curve right like like
one of
you know my games in the past have gone
like three out of ten on some outlets
right and it's like
i do not think the game is a three out
of ten right but that person did
and fair enough like that's cool
hopefully
i i worry that we as a culture just put
make metacritic out to be like a
scientific appraisal of the
quality of the game but that's what
happens when you start putting bonuses
on it that's what happens when you start
build and when you when you teach an
audience that metacritic is the be all
and all of
is game good that's where you end up and
i think i think it can get regurgitated
back into the minds of the people who
make games and i certainly pay more
attention to our metacritic than
metacritic schools than i should you
know because ultimately who cares if
someone thought it was
excellent and someone thought it was
[ __ ] cool i made you know someone
thought was excellent that's great my
favorite was
uh when the night of the uh election
like the us presidential election sam
barlow tweeted
where it was like you know
after after midnight okay stop counting
the votes stop counting the votes or
whatever and sam barlow was like every
developer wants them it's like 92.
yeah that's the thing and that first
couple of hours on metacritic are a
nightmare for a developer because you're
watching that number wobble up and down
you're like
oh please stop reviewing it no no no no
more reviews more reviews
where i wished that i didn't have to
and it was for um werewolf within
for ubisoft uh it was their it's their
vr
werewolf yeah i think that's what it's
called it's theirs
yeah and it was just so buggy that um
like you'd have a rule book and
sometimes when you join the lobby the
rule book wouldn't load in the pages
would all be empty meaning
you couldn't play it you'd have to leave
and rejoin like two times to the extent
that like while i was playing that game
other players had figured out their own
ways around the bugs that they were able
to tell me
um because that's the only way that you
could play the game was like figuring
out the ways around it and so i
i you know it was a puzzle and it's
sometimes you join muted and then that
was a really difficult one because you
wouldn't know you were muted for a
really long time
it was tough um but i i wrote the review
and i emailed ubisoft and i was like
listen
realistically are you going to fix these
in the next couple of weeks
because if i had the opportunity to i
probably would have pushed the review
i would have made it a later date if
they could be like yeah these bugs will
be fixed at this point in time but they
were ultimately like no
like we can't change these anytime soon
i'm like i have to publish this like it
is my job to get this thing published
because people can buy it right now
so i have to tell them about it but it
really did suck to have to do that to be
like this thing probably
will be fixed in a couple of months but
i have to review it as it is now and it
is not financially viable for review
scores to be updated i think they are
doing a better job of that
that is a thing that that has definitely
uh changed in the industry or that side
of the industry
but it's still like for a game like
werewolf that's never gonna traffic well
on a site like ign it's not worthwhile
to have me
you know go back and spend another eight
hours playing this social
murder game just to update a review
score that nobody's looking at which
it's brutal it sucked it really sucked
to have to do that i was like i have to
do it i'm really sorry like
it's a huge bummer that this turned out
this way and thankfully they were really
professional about it they fully
understood but it still definitely sucks
to have to do
i have to say also this is kind of very
very minorly tangential off of that but
the idea of
star wars john williams
i think the idea of tying financials to
bonus uh tying financials to metacritic
scores is very bizarre because you can
have a really high score and be a
financial failure so at that point
like so wouldn't you discourage yourself
yeah either the publisher is just
hemorrhaging money unnecessarily or
there would be like a double contingency
of presuming commercial success
and a high metacritic score and it's
like why not just go for the commercial
success at that but even like the the
commercial success thing's a problem as
well right because you could be
you could make the best game ever and if
your publisher pulls the marketing
budget then
you'll not sell as many units and that's
it's almost like what we should do is
not build in bonuses which only
ultimately benefit the bosses
because they get to withhold them in
cases where something goes wrong
the bosses should accept the risk of
financial risk because of problems
the studio owners the publishers the
platform holder the people who are
making an investment and taking a risk
should assume the risk because they're
also going to be the ones to assume the
massive profits if something goes very
well
and they should pay their stock
i've i've only ever gotten like this is
your salary every year
i wouldn't want that though if i worked
at a studio and it was like hey man so
this is the salad that you're gonna get
and even if it shits the bed man if it
fails
we guarantee you're gonna make this much
money it's like okay what if it does
like a gajillion dollars like good
dude what we're gonna do is we're gonna
actually give you more
that's one way of looking at it and i
think it's i think that's valid well you
can do royalties that's one way a lot of
studios do it
i think the problem there though is
there's a lot of people involved in the
process of whether the game makes money
you don't get basically if you're an
employee of a company making a game and
you're a team member if you're joe blogs
in animation because we
referenced joe earlier joe blogson
animation doesn't get to decide any of
the major decisions in the game that are
going to impact the review scores or the
sales
they don't get to decide whether the
game's ultimately good they can do their
job very well or they can do their job
very badly
but ultimately especially in a triple a
game
joe blogs's individual impact is not
going to steer the ship
one way or another and therefore if
you're working in teams if you're
working on the best games in the world
that always make a bajillion dollars
then great bonuses are brilliant but if
you're working
as most games developers do on the stuff
that isn't
the big kind of key release of the year
uh for a platform
you're never gonna see that bonus and
bonuses are often kind of hung over
people in that way
i would much rather as an employee back
in the day when i was not a studio owner
which obviously is a very different
position now
as an employee i'd much rather have a
better salary
because that's something i can control
because my salary is based on my
skill set i prefer that too much my job
and my promotions unders
understand not just salary but the job
security of hey we made a ton of profit
which means we get to make another game
yeah oh yeah like to me
yeah that strikes right here the
industry does a lot of weird things like
this as well in terms of holding bonuses
back so people can't quit during crunch
there's lots of
uh shady [ __ ] but i don't know how that
would scan like i just think about
myself in that situation
and i signed it was like burgeoning
studio we just started off
we got a five million dollar budget to
make this game it's okay it's like so
all we can do
we're gonna smile at the idea of like
five million people
if you if you can if you can put me in
touch with the person who wants to give
five million to a burgeoning studio i
want to have a call with that person
i'm just i'm using it as a number yeah i
hear you i hear you i'm sorry i
i hear you i apologize it's like that
means that we have the ability to hire
these people these people these people
and we are maxed out here's our burn
rate that we believe that this game is
going to take us 24 months to make in 24
months we can burn through this money
and this is the game we're gonna make
and that game goes and does [ __ ]
among us numbers it does
animal crossing numbers it's insane it's
like holy [ __ ] we're printing
money but we're gonna make another game
you're like
how much money did this thing i mean i
agreed to do this because it was the
it was the first game that you did it's
like yeah
and how much money did she go we made a
shitload of money we're getting
new offices and we're going to be able
to add more people it's like
okay wouldn't that make your job better
so there's a couple of layers there
there's a couple of layers there you
one is you're an optimist troy because
there are a lot of games that came out
that weren't among us
last year absolutely hundreds of
thousands of games
but that's that's what i'm saying
there's there's so many situations where
it's like
we didn't make anything because i i
don't agree like this the sustainability
of the studio if it falls below it gets
an 85 versus an 86 we shut down i
i hate that and that that's that's a
flaw with with the system
but it's like here's your money this is
what we can pay you
and you've got studios that are
leapfrogging and going we know that it's
going to not only take 24 months to ship
this game
but then it's going to be another 24
months before or maybe even 6 months 18
months
before publisher decides to review
everything that we did
and then either decrease or increase our
budget to be able to make our next game
so there's we have to be able to not
just do our burn but then
ramp to our next round i get all of that
and we're going to have to lay everybody
off or get rid of we don't do that you
don't see that well what i'm saying is
like
you skip you scale using yeah yeah yeah
people yeah
right and then you go down to your core
so there's all that that's going to
happen
but if i go hey man you're invested in
this company
and we really want you to stay and what
we're going to be able to do is pay you
your salary of a bonus if if we hit this
like your entire year's salary will give
you as a bonus if
if we hit this number and i hope that we
do that's life-changing money to people
i can tell you 90 percent of people want
the
10 increase now forget the bonus like
that like
someone who hires people that's what
they want less people get paid
do you understand like if you go okay
we're going to go ahead and
increase that money now but that means
that we do not hire as many people
because
this money that we're given up front
stays the same we only get
our five million dollars one million
dollars over 24 months
we don't we can't mitigate our success
or our failure now we can't we have to
do that
once we once we get there it's a
different approach there are different
studios that take different approaches
like mine for example
is focused on you know we pay people
pretty damn well
that's our approach and we have some we
have a smaller team
than our budgets you know would be spent
elsewhere
there are other studios who take the
same money we spend and spend it on more
people and pay them worse
and then have bonuses and yes if those
games well less
pay them less yeah that's i mean that's
my definition of worse it's not a
synonymous one
they're making me worse yeah but that's
fine that means that someone's
unemployed because of you if you want to
flip the coin
yeah yeah that's you could absolutely
frame it that way you could have saved
when i say it pay them worse pay them
less it's like i'm giving more
jobs to more people as opposed to
fewer people making more money i don't
know when i was at ign and i was working
my ass off and crunching all the time
and then we'd have a meeting and they'd
be like we made millions of dollars and
and then i'd not get a raise and they
were like we just don't have any money
that was like a [ __ ] you it wasn't like
you should get the rates for sure you
should get the raise in that scenario
yeah yeah it was always just paid her
more from the very beginning exactly
that's why
well they shouldn't say is igen
shouldn't take lana into a room and say
hey you're doing great if you continue
to do great and if the company meets
some metrics that you have no impact on
we promise you that we'll give you some
more money that's going to take the
stable salaries
you did evidently you take this i would
say that yeah and i dude i totally hear
you
i think troy your industry
functions so differently like acting
functions
so differently where this stuff is
concerned that
how so uh i mean what's that what's the
yeah back pay is a thing and then
there's like the the like the plus ten
percent
thing are you kidding me do you not get
you don't get like deals for like
royalties and back ends or stuff sorry
it's a very
whole strike was about by the way i
don't believe actors are deserving of
you don't automatically get royalties
that's because that's not the way
the reason why royalties came into play
is because there was
outside advertising dollars that were
surrounding
certain things and there was the reason
why you get royalties
is because it goes from here to here and
then plays multiple times
that's where royalties come from a game
is not that way
game is not entertainment game is
software definitely it is not operating
in the cinematic
people so when you
so i get up i negotiate my money up
front
and i go this is what i'm gonna you're
gonna say that this project is gonna
cost this much
it's gonna take this much time and this
is what i would like and they go
no and we either have a dealer we don't
our walk away
so that's that's what we're arguing for
that's that's the salary model like
that's not
that's the non-bonus version absolutely
yeah absolutely i'm saying for a studio
but i'm also not an employee
i think he's an employee troy no
i dude i i come in and i i i do what i'm
supposed to do but
there are practical different employee
of your house there are no but
you have the same in my opinion you have
the same like right to be treated
professionally i feel like i can speak
to this anybody is second-class citizens
but i will say this
there have been projects where i've come
in as like this is going to be my
involvement as an actor
and the current way that it works is
that i get paid this much for my acting
services
now what if i were to come in as a
producer what if i were to come in as a
consultant whatever come to be able to
do that
and i was able to if this thing does
gangbusters and you can go hey man
your job made an impact and move the
needle on this
we would like if we hit this metric we
would like to be able to give you more
money i'm like absolutely
okay so that's where the bonus kind of
approach comes in is when you're moving
beyond
doing the performance i see what you're
saying i don't believe anybody's
entitled to a bonus i'm just saying it's
a it's a wonderful way to go
look man if if rising tide floats all
boats and if we hit the numbers that we
want to hit
everyone's going to do a bonus sounds
great i'm sorry
but i mean i've never worked anyone
that's had one and i think that i would
take the
the standard security but i did just
want to mention that sometimes this
happens to me with youtube sometimes if
i get a sponsor for a youtube video
they'll be like and we'll give you this
much extra money if the video gets a
hundred thousand views and every time
i'm like that means literally nothing to
me
because i have no idea how anything will
perform so when they even offer that i'm
like
no that you don't it doesn't sweeten the
deal for me in the slightest because a
video can do 100 000 views that i would
never expect it to or it could do 40 000
views when i think it'll do really well
it is impossible to tell
that i'm like this this offer means [ __ ]
to me
the composer equivalent to that is using
soundtrack album royalties as
a bargaining device in composer
contracts because sometimes those turn
out to be quite
valuable and sometimes they turn out to
be worth absolutely nothing
yeah and it's entirely dependent on what
the audience decides in mass
and uh so like it can and yet it can
become a contentiously
like major part of a negotiation because
every now and again a soundtrack is
like an undertale that just makes right
outrageous amounts of money
um but it's it's so it's it's rare
enough that most of the time
i'm like i'm not willing like for
example if it's a project i really want
to do but they're basically saying
you know we're going to give you you
know a point on the soundtrack album
meaning like no
i'm going to write all this music and 99
of the money that it makes in the
secondary market will go to other
stakeholders like there are arguments
there are valid arguments as to why i
would not be the only one entitled to
that money but the idea that i would be
the
far and away minority shareholder in
what is essentially
solely comprised of my work it does seem
wild but at the same time i've given
that up
plenty of times because i'm like i'm not
willing to walk over this
and they are and so i still would rather
work on the project at the end of the
day
knowing that likely this is not going to
be worth much money for anyone
anyway because most central problems
just don't make that much money
so this is the thing i think that i
think this is the factor that we
definitely need to kind of frame though
is that with all of this stuff
yes of course contract negotiation uh
you know
ultimately it's two people coming
together and finding a deal that both of
them can live with
we are all four of us are in a really
privileged cool position
where because of our reputations because
of the things we've done we
are we're able to walk away we're able
to take risks we're able to decide oh
this is a project i'm going to do for
the love this is the project i'll do for
the money
if you're an employee a staff a studio
in a staff role
you don't really have that option so
you're not going to be able to
choose to opt in or out of things based
on
my very first movie that i ever did or
very first acting job
um on camera was was for a cbs pilot
that never went
and i walked out of my my
little trailer that i was surprised that
i had and across the
trailer for me was lou diamond phillips
and he was smoking a cigarette and i was
like i want to talk to lou diamond
phillips about young guns too
so i went over and i said hey man can i
bum a smoke i had just quit
and that was gonna be my first smoke
back i was like hey of course
and i immediately dug in i was like man
i got a question i'm just starting off
and he like was super kind and gracious
and took me under his wing and i said
at what point in your career do you stop
i was like i haven't even got the
question he goes you're already wrong
because if you think at some point in
your career you will have arrived
in order to ask for something you're
wrong you never will
and what i would encourage you is that
if you truly believe
in something you ask from it you ask for
it from the jump
and i think you always have the option
the consequences are always the same you
can just maybe mitigate those
consequences better once you have
achieved something other than this
you've got more money in the bank or
whatever
but do not think for a second that every
time that i've said notice something or
walk away
there is the fear of god that is in my
heart
because there's more at risk than just
my pride there's my family's well-being
there's my son's education
and when i say no to something i said no
to something today
there was always the fear and i talked
about pam i told pandas last night it's
like
no other job do you have to go i'm
starting from scratch
every day or every month
like a doctor you got this that salaried
employee
they don't wake up every morning going i
have to do this all over again
every day and that is the life that i
have chosen i have the option
yeah same the same thing for you we're
all
any freelancer basically is trading is
trading
uh selectivity uh and
uh you know potential diversity of
opportunities
and you know it's not freedom the
ability to make your own
hours no it's not freedom and all these
things uh you know
it's the brass ring baby but the truth
is is that that that person who's just
now starting off
i love the story of tom cruise on the
set of uh
um the outsiders i think it was
uh one of his co-stars that came with
who was telling the stories like we had
to share a room together it was rob lowe
or something so we had to share a room
and he threw a fit because he had to
share a room with someone
for the for the callback i think it was
or the screen test
and he was like tom cruise knew then
that he was tom cruise
and i was like that was his first movie
and i'm like man if you know something
now don't be a dick
i'm not saying be a dick about it but at
the same time it's like
hey miss this is this is the line that
uh i'm i'm i'm not willing to cross
i was like well we're not gonna hire you
then it's like then that's what i'm
gonna do
there's some checks that you don't
deposit in a bank and i think that's one
of them it takes a long time to learn
it it takes a lot it took me
a long time to learn and i still
struggle with it every time don't think
that i'm i feel like i'm in such a
privileged position to be able to say no
there is fear every time but i just i
i refuse to operate out of a place of
fear and i choose to operate in a place
of faith going if i say no to that
there's a yes that's coming and i got to
go find it
i love all of you i think you're all
fine
um but on that note
you